I only applied to Cambridge got into
Cambridge and I thought that was going
to be the beginning of my full agency it
was actually the beginning of the end
I suddenly
was exposed to sort of a culture of
critical theories which told me that I
was a victim and that I was at an
inherent disadvantage
and that really messed with my mind I
got very depressed was an antidepressant
was suicidal for my second year
throughout my life it was white people
who cared for me it was white people who
loved me I had been abandoned by my
black mother so
there was an inherent contradiction in
what I was being told
you're a young woman who is at Cambridge
University you get a degree from there
your opportunities are Limitless and yet
you're a victim with uh
I mean it's it's just bollocks
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster and
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest today is a fellow YouTuber whose
channel is called kidology she goes by Z
palsy welcome to trigonometry thank you
for having me it's a real pleasure by
the way if she looks tense it's because
we did about five attempts at the
introduction and we totally ruined it
hello and welcome to trigonometry mate
why are you laughing I don't know our
brilliant guest today is a fellow
YouTuber whose can't Channel
so welcome you're probably looking at us
like we don't know what we're doing
which is accurate
um before we get into the conversation
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what's been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
well I am
who makes content about everything and
anything to do with modern society and
that sometimes includes myself
um why I'm here today uh that's boggled
me because I cannot imagine why you'd
want to speak to me I was absolutely
flattered so thank you but I tend to
just make content that is about the
issue that young people are going
through particularly with regards to
relationships modern politics identity
politics specifically mainly because I
have quite a unique upbringing and quite
a as a result a unique perspective on
I think a lot of the contradictions
about living as a modern individual in
modern societies like Britain and or
primarily the US well you've got our
attention already I notice you're fully
integrated into British culture and that
you were incredibly self-deprecating to
start with but you mentioned having a
unique background and you really do have
a unique background tell everybody about
that
well
let's start all the way from the
beginning I was abandoned by my mother
alongside my older brother and we were
then separated into different
fostering situations I was fostered by a
white South African family of women sort
of an intergenerational
great-grandmother grandmother mother the
mother adopted me but unfortunately she
had severe mental health issues bipolar
and so I was raised by her mother who
was a Pentecostal and was devout and
this was
post-apartheid to South Africa the late
1990s early 2000s and
she was
basically believed that the Lord spoke
through her and I would I was sort of an
example of the potential of South Africa
or the potential of being a rainbow
child of the rainbow nation and the
potential that black South Africans
could have if
raised accordingly
um so no pressure then
no no not really no no so I was very
devout very religious and as a result my
life was quite Blissful until it wasn't
until unfortunately she
uh developed or contracted developed
cancer and we believe that God was going
to heal her obviously obviously he
didn't and so unfortunately she passed
away and I was then
I then went to boarding school in South
Africa how old were you when she passed
away I was 13 going on 14. so yes yes
and this was quite a long uh she was
sick from when I was about nine years
old until 13 so it's a very long and
slow uh death regressively but I was
then in boarding school for the last
year of her life
and then suddenly I was told that I'm
moving to the UK to be fostered by her
ex-husband who was a 75 year old white
South African uh who lived in Zimbabwe
when it was Rhodesia and he was very
mournful of the good old days before the
blacks came into power and so I moved
here I was given a day's notice and I
came to live with him uh first thing I
was
first thing I saw going into flat was a
poster saying kill the blacks farmer
back from his uh day serving in the um
zimbabrian or Rhodesian Civil War so uh
yes we didn't get on
[Laughter]
you are British that is the most
understated thing I've ever heard of
money yeah opposed to saying kill people
like me we didn't get off yeah yeah yeah
yes yes I think
just upbringing because it made me very
it has made me very understanding even
though I'm not a Believer now it's made
me incredibly
understanding of things that I think
otherwise I wouldn't be so understanding
of so
we were just from completely different
worlds and it was very awkward for him
to live with me and also to sort of
acknowledge that I was a part of his
family
so it was quite contentious I also did
not want to be here at all and
yes so I I was here
I then went to school and I found a new
religion which was getting into
Cambridge at any cost and I only applied
to Cambridge got into Cambridge and I
thought that was going to be the
beginning of my full agency
it was actually the beginning of the end
and uh I suddenly
was exposed to sort of a culture of
critical theories which told me that I
was a victim and that I was at an
inherent disadvantage
and that really messed with my mind I
got very depressed was an
antidepressants was suicidal for my
second year
yes it wasn't going very well but
I
then after I left Cambridge I sort of
didn't know what to do I was meant to go
to Oxford that fell through
and so I ended up working in retail and
after working in retail
I
have just been doing YouTube ever since
yeah yeah Francis
one thing I was going to ask you about
victim it is something I talk about a
lot as you know
I mean
there's a lot of people who are not
victims in your case there's a credible
claim there that you've had a pretty
rough life
and you could quite easily claim to be a
victim why was it that being told you
are one through this particular lens
why was that so distressing to you
I think it was because of who I was in
the context of Cambridge so I found that
I went to Cambridge and I suddenly
didn't have connections I didn't have
friends and I had to figure that out how
that was going to happen and
I was very quickly exposed to critical
theory critical race Theory particularly
and the assumption that because I was
black I was therefore inevitably going
to join all these all these black
societies which I did
but it became very apparent that I was
very native African and because of that
there was a disconnect in terms of our
morality a disconnect in terms of how I
saw myself and how they saw me
the other problem was that can I just
stop you let's delve into that because
what you just said there was so
interesting to me about how you saw
yourself how they saw me and because I
was a native African my morality was
different let's really unpack that what
do you mean by that
I think my
in terms of being native African
I think it doesn't when it comes to me
it doesn't really sort of pertain to
sort of the stereotypical native African
I think even in South Africa it was very
different to most black South African
children because I lived and socialized
exclusively with white South Africans
poor and rich white South Africans we
sort of uh were very socially mobile
throughout my time there so I was very
much I saw myself as white I really did
and I didn't really understand why other
people didn't see me as white and
fortunately in South Africa I was able
to play into that very much because of
how I spoke because I'd always be hand
in hand with a morbidly obese
Pentecostal Christian woman so um it was
okay
um but coming here and being here it was
very different in terms of how people
saw me and wanted me to act especially
in relation to seeing white people as
being oppressive to me when in fact
throughout my life
it was white people who cared for me it
was white people who loved me it was
white people who gave me purpose and
meaning never in my life did black South
Africans want to
Foster me wanted to adopt me I had been
abandoned by my black mother so
there was an inherent contradiction and
what I was being told especially at
University and
the fact that I was expected to
very much assimilate into this narrative
and into a community that really
conflicted with everything that I
believed and had experienced
and what because you've got quite a
fascinating insight and we'll talk about
the rest of what you're going to talk
about in a second into the way we
perceive race how
as an out from an outsider's point of
view
what do you think about the way we talk
about race in this country the way we
perceive it the way it's
the the narratives that are propagated
for our society about it
I find it's
incredibly unfreeing I think for a lot
of people I think it's unfreeing for
black people because I would say in this
country there is now this very
Americanized perspective that
everything can be reduced to some kind
of institutional or structural ill which
disproportionately affects
people of color are specifically black
people and it doesn't matter about the
empirical reality of for instance all
the black people who I knew at Cambridge
were incredibly wealthy black people
some of their parents were famous you
know they sort of were doing quite well
for themselves had gone to private
school but they were oppressed and they
really lived by that identity and it
didn't
it didn't correspond to what was
actually going on and so I think a
consequence of that is that
when you're living a fantasy the world
around you can crumble the real issues
are just not addressed and not looked at
and
the most successful
in the movement of Oppression and
victimhoods when
and so who do you mean by that so
examples or just the people who are
winning with these narratives
are those primarily thoughts thought
leaders or so-called quote-unquote
intellectuals probably I think the one
that stands out most to me is Ibrahim X
candy
um individuals who've made an entire
career around
this
I think very pop cultural interpretation
of critical theory right now which has
sort of really digressed from the roots
of critical theory I think it's
incredibly vindictive I think it's
ultimately
making a lot of people a lot of money
including Abraham he's now been signed
on to ESPN so he's doing great and
I think online especially in this fear
that I work in which is mainly video
essays about politics specifically U.S
politics it's very much dominated by
um a sort of sub cultural subset called
bread tube or cornbread tube which
have very unrealistic expectations for
people and of the world and I think
because
we are perpetually online it's very easy
to forget about everything else that is
going on and when you're making
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
you don't really have to think about
sort of the reality of things you can
just live in a world of
rather
revelatory ideas and ideals that will
never come to pass in your lifetime at
least now what ibra makes candy is just
being attacked by people saying he's a
racist because he's excluded people and
he wasn't anti-racist enough I'm not
surprised so it's uh the chickens are
coming home to always but you mentioned
um you mentioned real problems get
ignored when these fake narratives or
whatever you want to call them uh uh are
focused on and what are the real
problems
I think right now the greatest problem
that I think underlies everything is
a loss of any universal ethic or any
sort of anything that holds everybody
together
above that of identity I think right now
we've really resorted to looking at very
specific identity and almost tribalistic
elements that really separate us into
little groups in our liberal Society
and as a result we don't actually have a
society we don't have anything that
really
drives us as a people as a collective
people in uh I'd say Britain and the US
especially
and so I think when you are people and
you don't have
any allegiance to each other any common
language even I mean right now I think
it's very clear we don't have a common
language when it comes to something that
should be as basic as gender
um
and intergeneration thing especially
I think you're sort of you're seeing the
beginning of the end of I think a
project in the west that has taken
centuries to get to this point and is
now
not being realized I don't think we sort
of realize the consequences when we
killed God of what we were doing and I
think nothing has necessarily replaced
that execution
meaningfully uh and spiritually for a
lot of people and yes I think that's
underlying a lot of things
um yeah well we had a guest on called
James Orr
um he talked about the need for
something pre-political and it seems
that now we're in a place where
either your ethnic Identity or
increasing your your political identity
becomes
um it gives you meaning in a way that
you know other things actually ought to
do we were talking about wokeness
anti-workness Etc before we started and
a lot of people now
um that they that they're fully invested
in this uh world view which is
interesting to me because while I think
wokeness is really bad and I've always
opposed it I've opposed it not as an
identity thing I just think this way of
doing things is wrong
um but I do see that people are sort of
becoming very rigid in the way that they
see their role in the world and it it
happened with race and gender and all of
these things but it's also happened you
know just with ideas which to me is a
kind of a weird place because ideas are
supposed to evolve and change over time
and you're supposed to have flexibility
in in the way that you think about
things you're sounding very old mate
yeah well I am I am yes I agree I I
thank you so yes you were old
forgive me
um
no I would definitely agree I think that
intellectual culture in the west has
been in Decline since the 70s so I don't
want to sound too much like a historian
but I I do think that um
I think in the post-war years it was a
very interesting Time in the West in
terms of existentialism
um being able to replace sort of the
death of God that was so apparent after
the war and I think that really swept
the US and France and parts of the UK
um academically and because it was so
applicable to people of all Races
genders you know existentials feminists
uh you know all kinds of movements
adopted this and could really see
themselves in this because it was so
all-encompassing and expansive
and I think
in my opinion since the 70s especially
since
um second wave feminism early days of
secondary feminism
this idea of the personal being
political has taken over
and the personal in my opinion is never
political it's always
philosophical at its roots and that's
something that is very personal and
that's something that you have to take
responsibility for when the personal
becomes political suddenly all
responsibility is delegated to somebody
else it's somebody else's problem that
you're oppressed somebody else's problem
that you can't advance that you can't do
with your life what you want to do
you can completely invert morality to
serve you and I think that's what has
happened with a lot
of identity political groups and
movements now and do you think a lot of
people of your generation buy into that
idea the fact that you know the personal
is political and it's not their fault
they're not doing what they want because
the patriarchy or whoever it is is
stopping them from doing so yes I've
been canceled so many times for saying
just that if I say anything like that
um because there's no conception
especially with Gen z
um and I'd say Millennials as well
but with Gen Z there's absolutely no
idea in how to Fathom your identity
beyond that of it being a political
statement and being something that other
people have to recognize and other
people have to do something about they
have to change their actions in relation
to how you identify and you should be
able to engage with the world and walk
in the world safely securely and in the
exact way that you envisage and see
um
and ultimately have no responsibility so
the world just to translate what you're
saying into so that I understand it
better simpler language what you're
saying is essentially people carry an
idea of how the world is supposed to
adjust to them yes yes as opposed to but
isn't
I understand how stupid that is at an
intellectual level but at a practical
level are you not going to be slapped in
the face by reality on a daily basis if
you attempt to do this
a lot of people are treat to the
internet
and especially in my generation uh
Because the Internet allows you to live
in the delusion that the world
can change and also it means that when
you go into the world and it doesn't
conform to what you want it to be
you get very depressed mental health
issues arise
everything seems a lot worse than it
actually is
and I definitely see that as
uh
a big problem with my generation
everything is a lot worse than it is
about things that actually are not as
important as the things that actually
are a problem that can be an ought to be
addressed and which I think
we can all or to all agree on if we
actually care about those things yeah
we'll be back with Z in one minute first
we want to talk to you about the
sponsors of today's episode ag1 we take
ag1 to stay healthy and Stave off
illness whenever our schedule gets
really busy we used it on our last
America Tour where we were constantly on
the Move living out of a bag and working
every day one scoop a day meant we knew
we had all the vitamins and minerals
needed for the day we invested in our
health and had a hugely successful trip
as you saw ag-1 is a simple and easy way
to get all the nutrients you need each
serving contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients if you're looking for a
simple and cost effective supplement
routine we recommend you try ag1 and
they're giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase to claim
them just go to drink ag1.com
trigonometry go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry that's drink
trigonometry to claim this special offer
it sounds just incredibly sad because
you're denying that you have agency in
the world and that's so disempowering
how are you going to improve yourself
how are you going to build a career how
are you going to get married or do
whatever it is that you want to do if
you don't believe that you have agency
you're literally powerless
yes yes
um
yes and I definitely I definitely
especially when I was at University I
definitely felt that and I experienced
that I was in despair like constant
despair for days
and I didn't know what to do with myself
I didn't know how I was going to
navigate the world because what was the
point what's the point in trying to do
things when inevitably I'm going to fail
because I'm black and the systems and
institutions are against me and you end
up fulfilling that prophecy
just in yourself and
um
yes yes but that's so remarkable because
you're a young woman who is at Cambridge
University one of the best universities
in the world you get a degree from there
your opportunities are Limitless you can
pretty much go into any industry you
want any country you want
and yet you're a victim with uh
I mean it's com it's it's just bollocks
yes technical terms yeah
yes yes
it definitely is bollocks and it's was
so unhealthy
especially for me as somebody who didn't
get on with the black people who I was
in association with and they didn't like
me as well it wasn't just one-sided but
I was expected to somehow be in
Allegiance with these people who I
didn't have any personal Affinity with
and then not with white people who I
actually like culturally had a lot more
in common with sort of was able to
it just made a lot more sense to me and
the consequence of that is that I was
called racist and sort of uh self-hating
black which is something I'm always
accused of and
I think because people especially my
generation care a lot about what
everybody else thinks a lot
uh even though it's all about sort of me
me me me
um it's always
with the lens of somebody else and
everybody oh the narcissism always needs
the supply yes yeah it needs the supply
yeah that's the good stuff definitely
yeah so I'm curious how how then I mean
it's clear you're very independently
minded person and you think for yourself
blah blah but also how do you get out of
that despair once you find yourself in
that situation as you were at Cambridge
where you sort of feel out of place and
people are projecting their things onto
you Etc
yes well I think the thing with
the victimhood mindset I guess I can
just call it is that usually you find
some kind of power in it because people
recognize your victimhood and you find a
community or a tribe and then you know
you feel good about yourselves I didn't
find that Community because I wasn't
accepted by the black people that I was
meant to be in tribal Allegiance with
and that was very reminiscent of my
experience back in South Africa and so I
think because I didn't find the kind of
very
fake
uh emancipation through being a victim
that most people who rarely subscribe to
a do I wasn't getting that cathartic
feeling formats and I think the sort of
really important thing was that I
applied to Oxford to do an Ma and I
didn't think about the logistics of it I
didn't think that I had to somehow have
60 000 pounds to do an MMA I thought it
was just going to happen because I was
black and so obviously
I'm not even kidding um I did I really
did
um
I I couldn't fathom how it wasn't going
to happen I thought it was going to
happen I think because I was very
deluded as an undergraduate that I've
made it to Cambridge I got in then I had
this whole idea of being a victim and so
I was like oh that's why I got in
because you know they needed to fill
quotas and you know it was like that
and so obviously Oxford was going to
accept me and then pay for me they
accepted me but didn't pay for me so
suddenly I couldn't go and I had no
plans at all because my entire mindset
was I'm going to be an academic I'm just
going to be a political philosopher
that's all I'm going to do and lo and
behold the world doesn't work like that
and so I was alone I had no money I
didn't know what to do I had no plans
and I was applying for jobs everywhere
obviously I'd done no work experience
while I was at Uni because you know
exactly you know so um yes and the only
job I got was working at a grocery store
in Cambridge and so I spent a few years
there and that was very important for me
especially living in Cambridge not as a
student but as somebody with the
Cambridge working class
all of whom are white as well which was
very
um I had to really introspect about my
oppression
um
and
um they didn't care that I'd gone to
Cambridge and I had to work to actually
get recognition to actually Advance
um not that I Advanced very far I wasn't
terribly good at my job mainly just
socialize with people but it was very
good because I made so many friends work
friends with people who were mainly
white conservative
uh gen X's who I worked with and they
became like my default family and it was
very important for me to actually
see that and to experience the reality
of people who live in Cambridge who
aren't like Rich students cycling around
everywhere thinking that they rule the
world and that really
got me out of not just myself but out of
my depression definitely
um yeah and how did when they so I took
it what did you do at Cambridge what was
your degree in I did human social and
political sciences but I
was the one black girl who decided to do
a early modern political philosophy uh
so yeah
so when they were teaching I have no
problem with the teaching of critical
Rosary in the way that I have no problem
with the teaching of Marxism I I do have
a real problem with them going this is
you know how the world is because that
to me is not educational it's
indoctrination
so I guess my question is how did they
teach CRT critical race Theory did they
present it as this is the way the world
is was it slipped in through the back
door how did it work
what was a very interesting time because
it was sort of
I feel that the department was on sort
of the threshold of trying to implement
these dramatic changes but we were still
on the all curriculum and so there was a
lot of pushback whilst things were being
taught
by groups that were
decolonized the course or the curriculum
and
a lot of momentum for these things and I
got involved in that in my first and
second year and in my third year I gave
up on that and I decided I can't pretend
I'm I love Thomas Hobbes and old dead
white men I'm going to focus on that but
um it was taught
in my second year
based on two papers that I did it was
it was taught as if there wasn't really
an alternative you were taught about
these theories about sort of the
founding fathers you were taught about
sort of uh you know how things had
happened but this was the old way and
we're teaching you this because we are
in transition to the new way of what the
course is going to be in future years
and so we were sort of exposed to some
of that some new Authors who are
trickling in
um but
I didn't continue in my third year sort
of down that path I completely
um regressed
um back to sort of the very very
traditional Cambridge
education and the uh if you were trying
to explain CRT to one of your retail
grocery store workmates
what would you say that you were being
taught
I
I would say that I was being taught that
because you my colleague are whites
and I'm black you have privilege that I
can only dream off and
because of that
you need to
alter your ways alter your behavior be
more conscious and aware of the things
that you do and say to me and to other
people who look like me and how you
engage with us in the world because
a lot of what you do
will be interpreted as microaggressions
or taking for granted the advantages
that you have
so
you assuming I don't know
but I know how to
fold jeans
right but uh
I don't because I've
never worn jeans I don't know something
like that just something very like
minuscule something that would really
really uh
disrupts our friendship I would say yeah
you know what's interesting
we we kind of have this situation that's
happened in my lifetime where we've gone
from uh pathologizing difference
difference was bad
um you know if you stand out you're bad
to
uh now we're almost at a we then went to
a point where difference was diversity
is our strength to celebrate the
celebrate different celebrate this so
almost now where like difference is even
impossible to discuss in that sort of
context right so in the past it might
have been the case of oh so you're from
South Africa well I'm from Russia and we
would Exchange
uh visions of the world how we see the
world our experiences Etc whereas now
it's like almost well I best not
exchange with you any ideas about how
different things are because I might
offend you by not appreciating your
particular experience of the world it's
an interesting transformation don't you
think
yes
yes I think it's
a very regressive transformation I think
it's really
yeah yeah I think it's undermined our
curiosity in other people yes and with
that
I think a lot of assumptions are made a
lot of people then fall into stereotypes
and you miss so much potential I think
especially for things that are very
important like to me such as
intellectual curiosity and advancing
ideas that can really unite people I
think
it's really undermined our potential as
human beings now and really feeds into
sort of this
age that we live in of I think a lot of
decadence a lot of decadent thinking
about
how we are entitled to a lot of things
to a lot of people who actually don't
conform to our little boxed idea of who
they are and what they are yeah see so
there's a lot of people like me and
others you know that we say problematic
Boomers probably is what you think
you're a millennial man well not to them
I'm not no I'm a boomer
um who uh have a how can I put it
uncharitable view of the younger
Generations
but I do feel a real empathy for your
generation because
the way the internet has been you you've
only known the age of the internet
really
and the effect that it's had on you so
let's discuss what challenges are your
generation facing and what are the
problems and how are they manifesting
well I think the biggest problem I would
say is that we don't have faith or
belief in
the states we don't have faithal belief
in the actual political processes around
us of governments
we've really retreated into only
believing in politics that pertains to
Identity and very minuscule things
and I think because of that
the things that we do suffer with that I
think really sort of build up and lead
to a lot of our problems such as in the
UK I would say housing crisis is quite a
big thing that inevitably is going to
affect young people gen Z at some point
um I think
because of that and because we aren't as
politically invested and what is going
on policy wise I think that is
a problem that's a big problem
and then I think it works vice versa I
think government especially in the UK
doesn't have much interest in young
people we don't have any political power
we don't own poverty
um a lot of you don't vote
yes yes yes I think it's it's a two-way
relationship of distrust and disinterest
and I think once that's sorted out if it
is I have faith that it can be I think
a lot has to change
but I do have faith in younger
Generations I think in the next 10 or so
years
I think once a lot of this
even now online I'm starting to see that
a lot of people are becoming quite
disenchanted that the promises of this
particular path towards finding
ourselves through our identities that
it's not working and that things aren't
really being realized
in society in the way that we imagined
especially with everybody recognizing
our identities our ideas about the world
and what should happen with the world
yeah I I the thing that worries me see
is that you
as a generation are very Progressive
whatever way you want to do you want to
talk about it and like she she gave a
little interesting smile do you agree
with that assessment or not that my
generation has worked yeah oh yes
definitely okay okay yeah
what worries me is that the generation
who come after you
are not going to be and in fact there's
going to be a backlash and what worries
me is that the backlash ain't gonna be
pretty
the girls by the way sorry to interject
just some data the girls are incredibly
woke the boys
not so much yes and to be fair I do
think that that is going to be what's
going to stifle the backlash I think in
the same way that work hasn't worked out
because it's
based on a theory or a pseudo philosophy
that is very particular to very certain
people and necessarily has to have
people who you are against the
anti-works because there isn't sort of a
a united front or sort of everybody
believes in this or has the same
language and understanding of things I
think because everything's so fragmented
it can't go as far as it otherwise would
I think with the backlash which I would
say is more so in I think things happen
in the US and then sort of trickle down
here I would say in the US it's
happening now especially online with I
say far right thinking
I'm just thinking of
an intellectual online who's far-right
thinker called Bronze Age pervert I
think the problem with sort of this why
do we call ourselves that
yes he's uh he's got a very devout
following of young people especially
young men
um understandably but it's very much
based in
a particular kind of identity and
philosophy of going back to the Ancients
and this idea that our enemy is of
course young woman and woman who need to
be subjugated and I think
any idea that sort of involves
subjugating of another group of people
is not going to go very far for very
long so I think it's inevitably going to
happen the pendulum is going to swing
but I don't think it's going to swing in
such a dramatic way that it's actually
going to
what you're saying young boys desire to
get laid there's going to be he's going
to Triumph of whatever bigoted ideas
they've been told on the internet
yes yes that makes sense yeah you know
what I've always said this and and this
is true of forms of various forms of
feminism and it's true of uh all sorts
of red pill people and whatever any
ideology that seeks to divide men and
women is is always going to fail and
it's it's just because it's you can't
override that very basic thing that
exists between men and women which is a
force of attraction that's way stronger
than any of this [__]
hey KK do you know like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch-up is on locals
are War shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch them after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
you all on locals
I'm curious because you men and women is
an interesting subject that you talk
about it in your videos as well what's
going on in that world that you want to
talk to us about
I think men and women today
are so disconnected and in such
different worlds that we have no
ability
to do the thing that is so important to
all relationships I think which is
understanding and empathy and
forgiveness
um
we are
incredibly selfish and because of that
we are not finding the relationships
which we want so there's this
contradiction that men and women are
living with I think women are handling
it a lot better than men young women are
handling it a lot better than young men
and
how so
uh well I think because
this is the age I think of a woman
finding themselves finding some form of
at least political agency there's a lot
more definitions of what it means to be
a woman now uh it's really expanded
whereas for men
the idea of being a man in masculinity
not only has it not expanded and
diversified
toxic wow but also there is no healthy
option it's like being a man's toxic but
if you want to be a good man well be
like a woman yeah basically that's and
it's like
I'm not sure that's going to work yeah
you know talk about your feelings and be
emotional it does not work for men no no
no it really doesn't and I think uh
especially now at least since the 1950s
sort of the language of psychology has
really taken over in workplaces and now
especially on the internet everybody's
you know toxic uh boundaries all these
sorts of things all this sort of
language and pop psychology that's I
think really resonates with a lot of
women and sort of how we experience the
world and
um not so much with men who
understandably feel a lot of resentments
and I think because there is just such a
lack of empathy on both sides now I
think just our society generally has
become a lot less empathetic and I think
it's just trickle down to younger people
that
um we
especially women don't feel that they
need men as much or as readily
and I think men are also very impatient
when it comes to women when it comes to
relationships when it comes to
um
doing everything that they think that
they ought to do by a certain age sort
of by their mid-20s they sort of think
that they're meant to be aware their
fathers and grandfather grandfathers
were
um with a wife a home one kid on the way
at least and that's obviously not
happening
things are happening a lot later and I
found that online young men don't
appreciate that and are unable to
appreciate that and are also
experiencing a crisis of their own
identity and nobody cares
at least not really and
there's nobody to sort of guide them
exactly well no no there's Andrew take
you'll guide you no problem all these
people but you see I'm not saying that
in approvable Andrew take one bit what
I'm saying is something else which is
when you don't have healthy Role Models
this is what's going to come up that's
my point
yes yes yes men definitely look for gods
and without god well then you have to
find out men look for role models and
men look for inspiration and men look
for motivation because men want status
power money influence whatever all of
that and if you if there's no healthy
way of doing that they're they're gonna
look too and and the best example of
this is what's happening in the city
when you have young boys without Role
Models they are going to look to the
gang members for that so you know
agitates we always say this Andrew Tay
is a symptom he's not a problem itself
he's a symptom of the problem Oh yes
there's going to be another Andrew taste
there'll be loads of them there'll be
loads of them and they'll carry on
happening until men have a healthy way
of being men in society yeah yes yeah
it's
and for women
they face really really challenging
times because if you look at social
media Instagram I mean that's just the
way designed to make women feel
miserable about themselves their bodies
and their lives isn't it
definitely definitely yes I think the
worst thing that could have ever
happened
to young girls is Instagram I think it's
terrible it has caused so many mental
health issues especially in this country
for uh young girls especially during the
pandemic
um so
yes I think being a woman now and being
a young woman is very difficult
especially in relation to a lot of the
narrative online with these uh young
male thought leaders who sort of promote
this masculinity that really depends on
hating young woman or seeing them as
objects which then
rarely sort of reduces everything that a
young women are told about
especially now about sort of you know
pursuing a career working and you do
that but then online especially you're
demonized for doing that because you're
not having children and you're not being
the stereotypical
housewife of the 50s so yes I think it's
I think even though there's more options
of how to be a woman for women it's very
hard to not care about what everybody
else thinks you should be and women
really take that a lot more to Hearts
then I would say men do especially young
women I think it definitely I've noticed
because I have friends who are a lot
older female friends it definitely over
time it changes but it is very much a
process of becoming a woman and I think
right now
with our age where everyone is so
impatient uh we're very very lazy
everything is on demand I think
women and men both expect of each other
to have it all sorted out all figured
out he has to be making 200k a year
already she has to look like a bombshell
and have plastic surgery already and
somehow pop up like five babies for me
and still look up and that
obviously when you have just fantasies
of people
reality is going to seem absolutely
terrible and so I think that's really
there's a disenchantment of young people
and a disenchantment and a
disappointment with each other and
what's on offer
of the opposite sex especially
is this the reason why so many women now
are having plastic surgery and they're
having Botox in their early 20s and lip
fillers and all the rest of it
yes I definitely say that's the reason I
definitely think that it's um it's
trendy I think Trends now have sort of
become
many religions of their own I think it's
something to like follow for a time and
then the next thing comes so it's uh
getting a BBL or a live Villa
um nose job they sort of come in waves
and I think
it's nice to feel a part of something
and so a lot of women do these things
but also obviously to try and look
better than the next person on social
media to improve upon yourself to sort
of work on yourself we sort of I think
have become very desensitized from our
Human Condition physically and
anatomically and we sort of just see
ourselves as sort of things to enhance
um and that that's somehow going to make
us feel better emotionally and
psychologically which most of the time
it doesn't
it's so interesting that you say that
you know that we're looking for
happiness all of us but what you're
really saying is we're just looking for
it in the complete wrong place and
that's a that's really sad because it
just means that people are miserable
yes yes but the alternative is being
brave and accepting your Fates as a
human being and accepting how tragic The
Human Condition is and that's very scary
when
I would say there isn't the hope for
salvation on the other side the sort of
you've only got this life now and you
want to make the best of it and so it's
like live fast Die Young like who cares
it's very much you know I'm going to be
the best version of myself but that's a
good thing being the best version of
yourself is a good thing it depends on
what you mean by Best of having bigger
boobs makes you the best version of
yourself then you've got a problem uh
the you know the idea I'm not a Believer
either or a struggle with but anyway uh
you know this idea that life is finite
can be a hugely empowering thing because
it laser focuses your mind on like
I've only got one life I'm only living
this one I'm never going to be here
again so I might as well be honest be
brave say what I mean ask the question
that no one wants to whatever it is
right in this context
it can be very empowering but if if what
the best means is that you're liked or
more to the case your photo is liked
then let's [__] around with the photo
and make it look perfect that's the best
version of me so I think uh part of the
problem you're talking about is
our definition of what the best version
of you is has changed has changed and
the weird thing is is what I find
strange is that maybe it's because my
generation Millennials will say broadly
although I'm an older Millennial it's
like we were told you know have a family
do this get married buy a house buy all
of this and we chafed against that right
and so your generation no one even tries
to tell you anything I think no one
tries to be like do this do that
even though actually I wish my
generation had been not told in forceful
terms do this with the you know with the
jabbing finger but more like you know
life is about certain things it's about
having meaning and purpose in your life
now what is what do you think is going
to give you that well part of that is
going to be a fulfilling career but part
of that is going to be the people around
you and it may not be a wife and child
although it probably will be but it may
not be that but it's going to be the
meaningful connections you have with
other people around you and we were
talking before we started you know we
were joking around about what a
post-work world looks like that's what I
think it looks like it's a world in
which
you don't have trusty conservatives
telling young people well this is how
you must live your life but it is a
world in which young people do have
access to the wisdom of generations yes
definitely and the wisdom of generations
is basically what I've just said which
is life is about meaning and purpose and
it's about the people around you that
you love and love you that's it right
it's pretty simple and every generation
eventually comes there just a question
of how long it takes you to get there
and that's what I I wonder and I'm
curious to hear your take is how do we
how do we get to that point how do we
get to the point where younger people
have access to that wisdom without
feeling like it's being rammed down
their throat by old people that they
can't relate to
it's a very interesting question
I would say from my experience the worst
thing
that I experience is when
I would say for instance older feminists
online tell me that my life is empty and
that I'm unhappy because
I'm I don't have children or I'm not
married and it's interesting because
these are feminists who are sort of a
new cohort of feminists who are
um anti-progressive feminists people
like Louise Perry mayor Harrington yeah
yeah who we love by the way oh yeah and
we love you too but we love them we love
everybody yeah likewise likewise but I
don't think Louisa Mary would ever say
you're not happy because you're not
married
uh yes yes I I wouldn't say that in in
their work but when it comes to Twitter
for instance which I think is the place
where most young people engage with this
uh cultural ideas yes yes and I think on
Twitter so people do say things that
make you just want to grate your
eyeballs yes
um
you remember it's Twitter though right
I do yes yes but I think a lot of young
people don't realize that it's just
Twitter Twitter is sort of
uh somebody described it as the
marketplace of ideas now and uh that was
quite
quite horrifying but I think a lot of
young people do actually see it as a
place where real things happen
um and politicians obviously see the
potential of Twitter somehow
um but I think
I think a lot of how we engage I think
there just is such a lack of
understanding I would say with older
generations of how different the world
is growing up and being young today
let's change that what are the
differences that they don't get about
your generation
we're doing things
we are being a student
phones and smartphones and so we put it
out to the world so it's not just our
closest friends who see how stupid we
are it's everybody in the world and
everybody then judges you you go viral
and your life is ruined or you go viral
and like you know you open and only fans
so it's it's a very different way of
growing up and sort of
being exposed to not just a small group
of people but to a whole world of people
I think when it comes to for instance
relationships as well I think older
Generations tend to
see dating apps as well there's so many
more people now that you have just you
know the pick of the bunch so why is it
so hard for you to find somebody why is
it so hard for you to you know find the
perfect person and I think there is
often just it feels quite condescending
a lot of the time sort of when older
Generations engage with younger
generations and as a result younger
Generations are not interested in older
Generations
um and I do think that our
intergenerational divide is a very
negative thing I think um it's
interesting comparing extended families
or cultures where there's
um very strong extended familial bonds
like in the Jewish Community uh or in
the South Asian community in the UK
especially sort of looking at
how that unfolds relative to uh the rest
of the British population
so I do think
I do think we're speaking different
languages
and because everybody now not just young
people I think it is a specifically a
problem with young people but I think
everybody now thinks that they're an
expert and because of that
there's no relinquishing there's no um
stepping back listening to sympathizing
with or trying to empathize uh with
especially young people I hear so many
conservatives like Candace Owens saying
you know when I was 24 I was doing such
stupid things but then she'll say that
young men shouldn't marry a 24 year old
woman because she spent her day making
shakshuka and not going out and getting
married and popping out a baby so it's
I think there's just contradictions that
now with young people being so better
educated than ever before
but also being very very stupid at the
same time but thinking they know
everything
and then having older Generations who
are actually just as messed up have a
lot of problems I mean Boomers divorce
rates are sort of quite telling of um
I think a lot of issues there as well
yeah I think we just don't speak the
same language and I think we just nobody
is extending the Olive Branch to the
other
well we've extended it to you two
Boomers invited you on the show here we
are oh yeah thank you
that's not what I meant what I'm saying
is I'm Keen to Foster dialogue actually
I think it's very important I think it's
important that people from different
groups and backgrounds and whatever talk
to each other and understand where
everybody's coming from and I think you
know Francis I I have a lot less empathy
just by Nature I'm not very empathetic
person but I think it's not easy I can't
imagine growing up I can't imagine not
growing up I'm trying to basically
growing up in a world in which the
internet exists is not something I
experienced
and
compared to what people are experiencing
now I think that was Bliss yeah I really
do definitely and I'm I'm also for my
generation an exception because in South
Africa I didn't have internet or phone
so when I came here suddenly this whole
world opened up to me and so I don't
have
sort of a whole catalog of my stupidity
on the internet and so
I couldn't imagine what it would have
been like to have been exposed to
Instagram to YouTube to all of those
things to tick tock now
um and also you you sort of have to go
along with it especially as a young
person in order to be a part of
something in order not to miss out on
everything that's going on
um I think everything is a lot of young
people's sort of actions are driven by
fear ultimately fear of uh just fear of
not knowing what's going on fear of
being left behind of not fitting in but
also of being too normal that you sort
of Fade Into Oblivion especially online
so yeah it's been a wonderful
conversation so thank you so much for
coming on the show before we move on to
our section with locals and the
questions that they're going to ask
which only they get to see will finish
with our final question which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should be
oh
I think we're not talking enough about
the need for I would say an intellectual
movement that isn't based on identity
something that really is
all-encompassing of all people I think
we focus way too much on
the wrongdoings of people's sort of
actions and I think we've really fallen
out of touch with I think one of the
most important things in my opinion
which is philosophy and the importance
of philosophy and learning and
understanding yourself through the ideas
of other people throughout the ages I
think young people really
need to be reading more philosophy and
so I think
that is one thing we're not really
talking about I think definitely
you're going to struggle with that yeah
you're gonna struggle with that most
people aren't going to read philosophy
which is where we come back to the idea
of religion
some people just want you know the
Commandments they don't want the book
you know
I've been thinking about that a lot
myself yeah philosophy is great it
really is just fascinating it's
interesting but I don't know that all of
this gets sorted by people reading more
philosophy
I think it's a start I think this all
takes a lot of time and I think patience
is the most important thing that we
really do lack now in all spheres I
think we want Quick Fix solutions to a
lot of things and I think we need to go
back
and we need to understand why we are
where we are and that's going to take a
long time and a lot of patience and a
lot of uh
forgiveness of other people
um
and yes it's going to be challenging but
it will be worth it at the end
I
I have hope but we'll see we will see um
before we head over your YouTube
channels kidology people should check it
out and of course I want to ask you
actually because uh we've talked very
briefly about work and anti-work and I
have a sense you have some interesting
opinions about that so well I will ask
you about that but on locals head on
over there and we'll continue the
conversation including asking your
questions
she describes herself as a femme cell
female in cell
is that true yeah okay
um yes
[Music]
what are you talking about